what's the biggest problem facing New
York or London or San Francisco many
people would say the high cost of
housing as cities have become safer and
more economically successful they have
also become more expensive sky-high real
estate prices seem to be turning many
cities from places where ordinary people
can find a better future to boutique
towns that are affordable only to the
already prosperous the housing problem
afflicts not just the wealthiest cities
but also some of the poorest ones as
well yes
living in Johannesburg is cheaper than
living in New York but the cost of
housing can loom large - an economically
desperate South African when we think
about creating affordable housing we
need to remember that we need solutions
for both Boston and Kolkata and those
solutions are unlikely to be the same
the first question this section asks is
why is housing so much more expensive in
some places than others our high price
is driven by robust demand or limited
supply or both and will the high housing
prices that we see in cities like
Shanghai and San Francisco persist
buying a house is often the biggest
financial decision that a person makes
it seems sensible to think a bit about
what keeps prices high the second
question is what should be done to make
cities more affordable does
affordability require rent control or
housing vouchers should we be
subsidizing new construction or adding
units of public housing and who's gonna
pay for all these policies restricting
the supply of new housing is never going
to make housing less expensive but that
doesn't mean that government shouldn't
regulate new housing at all what if all
the new buildings just seem to be
apartments for billionaires should
London restrict Heights to preserve
sight lines of st. Paul's Cathedral
should Boston stop building to keep
shadows from falling on urban parks
should cities preserve old buildings as
a reminder of our urban past too many
great cities have become too expensive
we need to understand why and what can
be done about it
you